Colombia is marking one month since a wave
of deadly protests began. They started as an
outcry against a controversial tax reform but soon
turned into a national uprising against growing
poverty and inequality. Weeks of negotiations
to end the unrest have failed to bear fruit.
And the prospect of a peaceful solution seemed to
slip even further on Friday, when President Ivan
Duque announced he was deploying the military
after more people died in demonstrations.
Plumes of smoke tower above the city of
Popayan - like monuments to the resistance.
A month of protests has turned streets across the
country into smoldering battle-scars from
what they see as their fight for justice.
"The message we want to deliver is that we are
tired of so much injustice from this corrupt
government, of so much inequality.
We are not asking for any handouts.
We are not asking them to give us anything.
We're only asking for an opportunity to grow,
for equality - not only for the
rich, but also for the poor."
The protests erupted when President Ivan Duque
sought to raise taxes to pay for the pandemic.
The blowback forced him to kill the bill.
But the outcry continued - in outrage over
the government's handling of a crisis that's
seen unemployment double and inequality surge.
Attempts to broker an end to the
standoff have so far proven futile.
According to official figures, more than 45 people
have been killed, dozens more disappeared and
thousands on both sides wounded. But human rights
groups say the real toll is likely much higher.
And it's only likely to get
worse in the days ahead.
On Friday, President Duque said he's
deploying the army to epicenter of the unrest:
Cali, where at least three people
were killed in the last 24 hours.
"Let me be absolutely clear: As of tonight,
we begin the maximum deployment of military
assistance in the city of Cali
and (the department of) El Valle.
Islands of anarchy do not
have a place in our country."
Meeting with Colombia's Vice President on Friday,
US Secretary of State Antony Blinken expressed his
concern over the deepening crisis in the country -
backing the peoples' right to protest peacefully.
For now, though, the deadly cat-and-mouse
game on the streets of Colombia continues.